ich sage man kann das gar nicht genug
feiern was die tafeln was die
ehrenamtlichen leisten wir schalten wir
leicht zu ulrich von heesen der sich mit
anderen senioren bei der tafel
recklinghausen engagiert ulrich fühlen
sie sich nicht inzwischen doch
ausgenutzt von diesem staat welche der
staat hat im moment so viel um die ohren
die sind doch mit ihrer
regierungsbildung völlig ausgelassen
wir von der tafel haben uns überlegt wir
übernehmen jetzt einfach mal alle
staatlichen aufgaben wie jetzt alle ja
alle im rahmen unserer neuen aktion
richtig wieder hin groko wir wollen das
ja in deutschland fehlen ohne ende
landärzte und ja der staat tut nichts
dagegen
na und dann operiert man sich eben
gegenseitig kannst du heute alles
grübeln ist auch kein hexenwerk oder
stichwort marode infrastruktur der 14
er repariert jetzt am wochenende die
kaputte a20 und auch rückweg baut er
noch die rheinbrücke bei leverkusen
werden ganz allein würde sonst legt man
ja später als mehr wetter arbeitete als
alexander dobrindt
deutschland hat immer noch kein
atommüll-endlager kein problem jeder von
uns nimmt jetzt 23 versammeln nach hause
fahren
der staat kann den vw-vorstand nicht
zwingen nachrüstungen für diesen zu
bezahlen wir schon unsere edeka den
rucksack über rede ja welche das gebot
der stunde
nicht jammern einfach machen gut bei
einer sache der kümmern statt leider
nicht helfen
dieser material und personalmangel bei
der bundeswehr da müsste ich jetzt nicht
nein 1
vergiss es geht nicht wieder los kommt
gibt den karabiner her gibt es karabiner
zurück ins studio
ulrich von heesen
[Applaus]